hey guys I'm Greg Greg Greg Greg Greg
Greg Whitney is Brianne from hit or miss
mother's go watch her Channel please
it's a great great channel I was on an
episode with John and then John did his
own segment with her and I did my own
thing with her they're all there these
links are in the description box to go
watch those episodes I mean I want them
to get more views and I want those
videos because you know she had like
Jeremy Jones on there two other people
in those videos I feel kind of funny
I've had the kind of funny guys on my
mind a funny guy they're kind of funny
where's another thing they're called
kind of funny yeah no that's what this
shirt is from this is kind of funny
produce producer slash seducer is one of
the rare times a woman gives you
permission to look at her Channel
yeah I appreciate Cheryl I appreciate
that thank you my husband doesn't watch
the collapsium
all right so much the do't not twice
trailer I don't know what this is
I am a horror film fan aside from like
gore horror films like really Dori
I like suspenseful horror films all
right let's watch the dough not quite
sure did we're not good you learning the
song optimal when you kick strange
overly
we think by the way if you want an idol
he'll come again
[Music]
hey hey know that your relationship with
your daughter hasn't been easy to think
that which is a conspiring defeat has
been
I can't yeah they're just dogs around
her she opens the doorway between hell
into zombies gonna happen
[Music]
I'm underwhelmed
I'm underwhelmed you're underwhelmed yes
really
you joking no I am you're like oh that's
exciting I want to have that happen
sometime that I mean it does I feel like
this is a movie I've seen before yes why
it's just like show me something
different that's that's totally fair
totally fair assessment however any
movie life is like there's several movie
that like seem like that this film is
like drag me to hell of a plot of drag
me to hell it's not the most original
plot but its execution was very
different yeah I made for a really
entertaining awesome experience and that
ending man yeah spoiling there's
something about this too because I was
thinking that halfway through like this
this is very familiar this is neck scene
lot of Lee actually been done a billion
times already but there was some visual
imagery in there that I really felt like
I don't know made the trailer a little
bit rewarding I feel like you said drag
me to hell I mean this looks like it
might take yourself a lot more serious
and drag me to hell I don't know the
filmmakers involved in this and they may
just like too many trailers you see a
lot of them I don't know on I don't see
a lot of trailers I get benefit of the
doubts a lot there's something here that
feels like it could be you could still
work I don't know maybe it's the idea
maybe it's just a [ __ ] like but don't
knock twice title entries into this
because this could have been called like
something which for whatever yeah but
don't knock twice
add a little power which yeah actually
sounds like a teen with yes guest which
is a movie that I appreciate which is a
terrible film listen man there's still
doesn't boring to me though no you know
like a lot of times I see horror movies
with this kind of plot and trailers
where I'm like this looks like it's
gonna play out very slow
going to take a very long time again
going they're gonna try to be so
suspenseful which is silenced indirect
you just look like a dude crazy and
chaotic in it and I like I like seeing
that like chaos even if it's a bad movie
I like chaos and zombies when I'm in the
theater with my husband
and as trailer comes on yeah whenever
and all he doesn't whisper one word to
me like horny oh the one word for uh
like the one word for it yes this one I
think we get it probably a side as I he
loves horror films way more than I do
what do you like though I will crafted
thriller Bloody Disgusting underneath
what is love you think up what are you I
go saying oh they're a really good read
of all horses Bloody Disgusting is a
dot-com
no I as someone who does not will be
anything truly trust quotes on train
it's true a well-crafted thriller as a
little excerpt can also be led after
with a lot of their criticisms all the
part in the second exactly exactly
exactly because they do that like Bill
Koch take like a part of a bad review
but they're like but there's a little
couple in here that are that in there
people think it's a good review you know
yeah I just hope the witch stuff is
actually creepy because like any any
type of like supernatural stuff like
that like Benny Pond fingers in clubs
like this in description I ever made
sometimes any army to go there though
rightly very the imagination you mean I
was very much terrified by the movie The
Witch and there wasn't any of that sort
of that's true
grotesque bendy of fingers okay I guess
you're right
creepy right there what you depended on
is great but it was like all you could
see was the face that's what I mean I
mean there's some cool shop in this
trailer there's some really cool images
in this trailer and I'm hoping that the
trailer is just there's a lot of times
with films that try something different
they get put into a trailer that seems
you
because they're trying to make it appeal
that could be completely wrong you could
be 100% right I don't know you can be
wonderful in it what do we know
we don't make movies we just criticize
them I'm Greg welcome to the real
rejects you can subscribe today brands
and inner myth movies she what do you
mean important this movie this movie
when Erin said that for any of them
Atmos movies on Twitter follow her there
I was on a couple videos with her six
degrees of feature film did that with
John Humphrey Stacy Howard or co-host on
their film therapy where we talked about
emotions and you know how films affected
okay and there's all sexual questions
surprisingly there's all sexual
questions like what was your favorite
what was your favorite Michael Douglas
sexting at the ad my good one you know
what we're coming up on our 69 episode
of art oh do bring me on hot Michael
Douglas a lot of Brewers she's following
on Twitter you will see my pins tweet is
a picture where I recreated scenes from
80s films I did a few different 80 films
you can see those on my Instagram this
underscore movies there I'm gonna do
90's films next and I'm gonna do Basic
Instinct what's the white dress that's
gonna be one of them there's a famous
shot you know not da but up to the
payment